[Music]
it's just crazy
kareem elympios speaks out about the
bachelor in paradise shut down she saw
anointing in her highly anticipated
interview with Chris Harrison Tuesday
night elympios didn't get into many
specifics about what happened between
herself and Demario Jackson that day you
feel like Demario did anything wrong I
honestly don't feel like he did anything
wrong there's no way for you guys to
know that like she's like mentally
checked out like crane is not here right
now I don't think it's anyone's fault I
just think that you know it was just
really again an unfortunate annoying
situation but did express frustration
with Jackson tomorrow saying this isn't
it's unlike why he kind of just like
went for it it was like so on the
defense it was like I was never bad at
you or blaming you for anything the two
haven't seen each other since the
shutdown
he told Ichi he'd like to hear an
apology from her on TV an apology would
be great and he got one I have nothing
against you I'm so sorry that you had to
go through this I know exactly what it
feels like I go through a tail and I
wish you all the best and I'm just I'm
sorry
[Music]